if you look at yourself the same
analysis what are your best traits and
what are the the worst traits of Dr
Jordan Peterson
well I think that it's been difficult
for me to to optimally regulate my
irritation at times over the last few
years
and I'm trying to get that right to
figure out what the right because a lot
of things that have happened have
outraged me and then I'm not exactly
sure what emotional tone to take as a
consequence of that outrage and that's a
very complicated thing to figure out and
that's been exacerbated that problem by
the fact that I have been my family and
I have been the targets of very
conniving
um and and attacks and underground
attacks and that isn't stopping I mean
another time when your wife was fighting
a deadly cancer yeah
so was I so yeah yeah so it's very
difficult to regulate your your temper
properly under those circumstances let's
say and so I don't imagine where have
you most improved yourself do you think
as you got older
I get better and better at listening you
know and I'm better and better at
finding my way forward with the words
that I choose and that's just it's just
a continual in some sense incremental
expansion I probably got better too at
seeking out corrective information so
for example I got banned from Twitter
recently for making a statement that I
don't regret by the way but I had a
friend of mine two friends of mine Grill
me and I put that on YouTube that's
called Mean Tweets the it was an hour
and a half I said and one of them both
of them are very very smart people one
of them is more liberal than I am I
would say and but a very good advocate
for that liberal position and I I said
well let's hash this out there's some
things I've said that have made people
angry and you think I made them
unnecessarily angry and that I was
unnecessarily harsh in my tone did they
change their mind
they changed my Approach
you know because one of the things I
decided was that I would try to be
equally
judicious in my words but that I would
use a a calmer and more measured tone
and I don't mean use instrumentally I
mean that I would attempt to make the
effort to take as much unnecessary
emotion out of the
statement as possible and so I started
to do that in some of my more recent
videos I mean I tried to do that before
I think part of the reason that my
interview with Kathy Newman went well
was because I kept my head and I didn't
get irritated I had she's a good friend
of mine and I watched it with great
interest because I felt like you were
slightly on parallel lines and that
maybe she would do that interview
differently if she had her time again I
think that's highly possible yeah so so
yes I I changed my Approach quite
dramatically and what happened was that
I I read a telegraph article I recently
published about Deloitte and it was a
very cutting article and I was really
worried about publishing it because I
think it was the most cutting article
I've ever written and I read it on
YouTube very very calmly and carefully
and what happened was
I got
the response was much more positive and
much less negative so there was no
downside to it so people didn't say some
people said I you know I think that I
like your tone when you were more
aggressive especially on issues like
this but by and large it had all it
worked even better because I could be
careful in what I was discriminating
and then to Ally that with calmness
actually made it more potent rather than
less and so that was very interesting
and yeah and I mean we had a very
serious discussion about this my friends
and I I had a lot of people with me in
Miami when this was happening across the
political Spectrum we had a very healthy
debate for a couple of hours about
whether or not I had gone
Beyond some reasonable limit in the way
I was conducting myself Say on YouTube
and Twitter and some people were very
strongly advocating for more of what I
was doing and even harsher and others
were saying well you're alienating
people that you could otherwise
communicate with us it's interesting
about the listening like one of my sons
too my sons had come today because
that's one of the listen to this very
unusual well I've not even been to the
studio before so he just said to me
I said give me some advice you know you
love Jordan Peterson what's the advice
for the interview you said just listen
more than you normally do
so I've tried I've tried hard to ask a
question and let you answer right and so
I'm work in progress and I've been
interviewing people for 35 years but I
do think the listening as I've got older
I felt the same thing yeah it's a real
skill man listening is a is a powerful
tool actually oh yeah well there isn't
people there is nothing that people like
more and need more than to be listened
to you know and that's partly why the
left clamors all the time you know it
says look there's all these people who
aren't being listened to it's like there
are a lot of people who aren't being
listened to they're absolutely right
there's no doubt about that and I've
dealt with people who were
extraordinarily marginalized so to speak
in my clinical practice and some of
those people to straighten out their
minds they need like 10 000 hours of
listening because no one and I mean this
literally I've had people in my clinical
practice
no one ever listened to them their whole
life yeah and so when you they start
talking they're all over the place
they're disorganized they're hyper
emotional they're distrusting and and
they have to have all that conversation
that you would have needed to become
properly interested